we begin with a warning from the u.s
education secretary students and
teachers need to wear masks in schools
or in person classes could be shut down
again u.s coveted cases have surged to
106 000 a day raising concerns about the
upcoming school year the white house is
pushing vaccinations for everyone 12 and
older it's calling on schools to hold
pop-up vaccination clinics and asking
doctors to include covet-19 shots in
their back-to-school physicals for
student-athletes education secretary
miguel cardona joins us now to discuss
good to see you mr secretary boyd do you
have your work cut out for you
hello happy to be with you i'm glad
you're here because maybe you can help
people see the light let's start with
the governors in florida and texas i
wonder if you want them to stay after
school because they are already saying
they're going to ban the mass mandates
in their schools what's your message to
them
you know first of all across the country
there's that back-to-school feeling our
educators our students
parents we're excited this is an
exciting time of the year there's a vibe
about it and we're excited about it but
in those places where we see community
spread is really high we need to make
sure we're following the mitigation
strategies that protect students we're
talking about protecting students this
shouldn't be hard we want to protect our
students and staff and make sure that
they can go back to school and enjoy
in-person learning and not have
their education disrupted again
because of decisions that are being made
that go against what we know is best i
know i get what you're trying to do but
they're already saying listen we're not
going to do it you know this mass now
has become so polarizing and so
political and i'm trying to figure out
how we get past that to do what's best
for the students right you know let's
let's keep the politics out of it let
teachers teach let school leaders lead
they know what to do we were in this
position last year as uh education
leaders and let me tell you last year
when we were talking about reopening
schools and i remember being a part of
those conversations in connecticut we
didn't have the frequency of tests that
we have now we didn't have the science
that we have now we didn't have vaccines
then and we were able to safely reopen
our schools
we can do it for our students they
deserve it they've been waiting you know
they've had disrupted learning we owe it
to our students to get them in their
schools safely we owe it to our
educators we keep thanking educators
well let's show them that we appreciate
them by keeping them safe secretary
cardona one of the things last year that
was always looming was this idea even
when kids went back i know we kept
waiting to see well then is something
going to get shut down and especially
with the delta variant now it feels like
that's still out there what would have
to happen for you to say we need to
backtrack now and kids need to go back
home we can't keep them in school right
you know at the federal level i don't
have the uh
the authority to either mask mandate or
or vaccine mandate that's not what we do
at the federal level we provide guidance
and support and and funds i mean the
american rescue plan 130 billion dollars
for tools to get your schools open
safely but i think what we do uh is make
sure that we're creating a culture where
we're working really closely with our
health and safety experts because the
local decisions are critically important
it's really important for our local
superintendents
and our local states to be able to
navigate
reopening and unfortunately in some
cases having to scale back a little bit
based on the trends in their state based
on the trends in their community we want
to promote that by having our education
leaders and our health experts talking
leave the politics out of it when you
talk about giving that direction to
local communities another thing i know
that has come up and we don't have
immunization yet for 12 and under but
that seems to be on the horizon
hopefully soon
what about this idea like a measles like
a mumps like a chickenpox vaccine when
might we see an immunization required
for students going into school
you know
again
i focus really closely on making sure
we're doing everything in our schools
and i rely very heavily on the health
and safety experts they're the ones that
could answer that question best i i'm
not a medical expert and i would rely
very would would you want to see that
there's a reason we have it for those
other diseases right without question i
want to make sure that our schools can
be open with without interruption and if
that means that a safe vaccine can allow
that i'm totally in favor of it we have
90 percent of our educators that have
gotten vaccinated already
we're working on making sure that our
youth get vaccinated as well so that we
can get to the business of teaching and
learning which is what we do best mr
secretary it's vladimir gta let me ask
you a question about the federal freeze
on student loan payments which is
expiring next month will it be extended
yes this is a huge priority for us at
the department of education our
borrowers need support and our borrowers
need information so very soon you'll be
getting information on that while i
don't have an announcement today i can
tell you this is the highest priority
and we have to make sure that our
borrowers have enough time to plan for
repayment so that's take being taken
into account and at the end of the day
our department needs to do more to
promote protect our borrowers and to
support our higher education students in
general okay give me a one two three and
then we're going to let you go on how
parents can know it's safe for their
kids to go to school one two three go
number one ensure that the school is
prioritizing health and safety number
two make sure that the school has uh
social and emotional well-being
strategies to help our students come
back from the pandemic and number three
focus on academic excellence that's our
roadmap we're sticking to it all right
secretary cardona we thank you for your
time this morning i know we'll see you
again